make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are getting into the first
issue of the new volume of New Mutants
and I am excited about this actually I'm
pretty hyped about this it really is a
good throwback to the old New Mutants
comics but if I'm being honest with you
guys
Hickman is writing it and I love
Hickman's writing this feels more like
Generation X than New Mutants right lace
it's kind of it's kind of crazy in terms
of how this this whole thing goes down
but what this does is this initially
picks up with Reince and Claire with
with really like Wolfsbane now here's
the thing here's it's like a really good
way to open this and the reason why is
because Wolfsbane is one of the original
New Mutants right so the way this played
out in Marvel comics like this is beyond
this is like decades ago
why eons and eons ago so the way this
played out is you had the x-men and the
x-men were a really popular team and so
Marvel basically came along and I want
to say it was Jim shooter who went to
Louise Simonson and Chris Claremont and
said give me a new x-men title or a new
mutant title if you don't I'm gonna have
somebody else do it so they ended up
creating the new mutants and and the way
this played out is and it was kind of a
cool revelation the way this played out
is you had mutants out there who were
like usually discovered by Charles
Xavier right like he put on his cerebro
helmet and he'd look around and say
there's a mutant over there and then
lock all the x-men would go there he
would go there whatever the case says
and they would talk to them and
sometimes it would join the x-men
sometimes they would they would just say
screw off I'm gonna go commit crimes and
then like the action would fight them
later on or something on those lines the
cool thing about this is that you had
more McTaggart and more macabre it was
basically just a mutant geneticists at
the time now hitman has changed a lot of
her character as part of house and
powers of X but back then she was just a
meeting geneticist but what would happen
is that if she came across the mutants
who didn't understand how their powers
worked or she didn't understand how
their powers worked she would work
alongside them to understand it on a
genetic level there were other times
where Xavier would come across a mutant
and he wouldn't understand how their
powers work so he would send them to
Maura McTaggart and she would basically
you know work on them and try to figure
out what the case was it was a cool idea
but rave Santa Clara was a mutant who
was basically found by Maura McTaggart
and brought in and then ultimately the
means on new moons were formed after
that but the cool thing about this is it
rains and Claire is one of the many
mutants who's been resurrected by the
five and that's officially what
Hickman's calling them now right the
five mutants who were responsible for
being able to resurrect mutants now
here's the reason why that matters is
because by saying it's the five what it
does is it makes those five mutants
essential to the process of resurrection
if any one of those five mutants die the
ability to resurrect mutants basically
goes away
come on and so as a results that you
need to have them there in order to be
able to pull that off so you kill any
one of those five and most likely the
x-men cannot resurrect you mutants
anymore but as a result of those five
mutants who have basically been killed
off over the years are systematically
being brought back right so you've got
Danielle Moonstar who basically makes
her return
you've got karma who makes her return
karma was interesting character right
technically they they call her Shan and
I guess it's really how you pronounce it
but it's X I apostrophe eight and I
think is how it's actually spelled she
had the ability she had Teleca I'm sorry
she had telepathy and she could possess
people which was really really cool uh
Wolfsbane was basically like a little
mini werewolf kind of characterized you
get turned a little scare does it look
like a werewolf it was it was kind of
cool the way it played out and then we
have the return of mondo I don't know
why mondo is back here mondo was a
terrible character okay so the idea
behind this is in the old Generation X
comics right it was Generation X number
three and 95 by by Scott lone L and they
introduced mondo as this this mutant
that had the ability to basically
influence or to manipulate any kind of
biological organism that was out there
right so he could interface and like
take on the properties of those various
things but mondo was introduced as a
friend of Mo frosty on her sister and
the younger sister Emma Frost tried to
like you tried to basically get herself
in the Hellfire Club by having him
captured it was weird anyway um
ultimately they're defeated by
Generation X and and the result is that
mondo is brought onto the team this runs
for about five years until Jeff a bear
gets on it gets his hands on Generation
X and in 1999 or 2000 I want to say it
was February 2000 there was a story that
ran an issue 60 and 61 and what you
ended up learning is that mondo as he
existed in Generation X up to that point
was not actually mondo it was a clone
created by black Tom Cassidy who was
designed to infiltrate Generation X and
it was basically a clone of the
supervillain mondo who worked with black
Tom Cassidy it was weird
it was comics in the late 2000s didn't
make a whole lot of sense the way things
are going down here this looks like the
mondo clone is really kind of what it
looks like in terms of what this guy
being a good guy and never really being
a bad guy plus there's no real reference
to him ever having been a villain before
at least that's kind of how it seemed
anyway so regards to the circumstance
the cool thing about this is that Doug
Ramsey cipher basically walks up on and
says hey man because you can interface
with like biological organisms and
things along those lines you don't
organic and inorganic matter see if you
can interface with your color because I
want to talk to it I just want to see if
it can happen and it's kind of weird
because ultimately Kirk oh it does right
it interfaces directly through through
and talks to Doug Ramsey which is kind
of cool but it's interesting because
what it does is it really ties the
nature of mondo at least seemingly into
plant life right the fact remains here
and then of course you've got Robert
Acosta who's basically been brought back
you've got Danielle Moonstar who's here
is it really is kind of a reunion with
all these new mutants that are here the
only person that's missing is Sam
Guthrie as cannon ball because at the
moment he's currently in Shiar space now
in reality this statement kind of
confuses me a little bit and the reason
why is because Paige Guthrie the sister
of Sam died during house and powers of
XY she was husk she was one of the
mutants that was killed during the
assault on mother more Icarus has
basically been dead since decimation
right so it's like the aftermath of
decimation and the war with William
Stryker so I have no idea who Sam
Guthrie is with I have no idea who he's
with of the moment it's kind of weird to
sort of had that throw an INT so it may
just be that it's one of those things
where like Icarus was brought back in
some form or fashion and then for
whatever reason was sent to see our
space
I don't really know that's basically
where Sam is at the moment the result is
that the the new mutants actually end up
hitching a ride with Coursera and
starjammers now this is cool I love this
idea of the new mutants working with
Corsair and his guys but the overall
gist here the overall idea behind this
is essentially the Newman's are
discouraged stuff up everywhere they go
and it's one of the funny things because
what you end up having is cypher and
mondo who essentially create one of
these aqua Cohen portals more or less in
this this bio a biome basically that's
ran by choke and it's kind of a funny
thing because as soon as chode realizes
what's going on like you realized
there's an imbalance in the various
substances that make up this biome and
then when he gets in there he starts
freaking out and the reason why is
because he had basically found or he'd
found these little plants that really
only bloom once in a decade right like
once every ten years and he had to get
these conditions perfect so we had to
spend years getting these conditions
ripe for these these flowers to bloom
and then when that happens it'll take a
decade before they reach their final
form and they've been killed by by
cypher and mondo we're just kind of
funny that's why I say this feels like
this feels like Generation X man I guess
exactly what it feels like Generation
Next New Mutants was pretty serious at
the time and I think Generation X was a
little more carefree in terms of how it
was done it's funny to me because any
wind up switching over to terraza and
magic and here's a funny thing Raza is
is not really the muscle of the team but
he kind of is right he's the muscle
insofar as he's probably the one who's
the best at fighting and the funny thing
about this is magic of course
having her sword and so on is a
prodigious fighter as well and so
there's kind of a bet that's going on
here
right between the two of these through
these guys who's gonna win the fight
between the two the idea is that
ultimately if Robert decosta wins then
they basically take Kentucky bourbon off
of course their which I'm proud to say
is cool because I'm from Kentucky we
basically have two two Bourbons in
Kentucky right like two Bourbons that
matter
you've got Woodford Reserve and you got
Buffalo Trace I'm a Woodford man more so
than a Buffalo Trace man but they're
both pretty good right so it's kind of
cool to see this little bet go on the
funny thing about this is that when this
goes down Lazo basically punch his magic
in the face she freaks out and then like
breaks his sword in half and cuts off
his robotic arm so like these little
these little moments you kinda remember
this for a second because it'll become
important once we get closer to the end
of the story but what they end up doing
is arriving at the spacestation
benevolence now here's the important
thing to understand about CR space G our
space is very much akin to like Kree
space or scroll space where it's a huge
section of the universe are really of a
particular galaxy that's kind of
cordoned off for them right it's their
Empire nobody gets in nobody gets out
unless they approve it so the star gamer
is basically sneaking in here is a
pretty dangerous thing because the
starjammers and the the Shiar have a
pretty sketchy history right going all
the way back to the Phoenix of the Dark
Phoenix saga and even before then right
so they've been around for a long time
it constantly at odds because the
starjammers are basically space pirates
and so as a result of that course
they're kind of spits the story and
basically saying hey look this space
station is ran by some crazy religious
desperate and and the result is that if
you go in there like they're gonna bust
you and they're gonna take you to the
torture chambers and you know you got to
stay on the ship because it's really bad
stuff right it's really really scary out
there it's really bad stuff the problem
with course here is he's basically
dealing with teenagers he's dealing with
teenagers here and so as a result of
that you end up having Robert Acosta who
goes off and grabs bourbon so they can
all just basically have some drinks
which they're all probably underage they
really shouldn't but I guess I wonder if
space is considered international waters
like international territory like the
laws the United States don't apply the
United States of space those you guys
who understand this repeal referenced
but it's it's kind of a funny thing
because he's like okay well go get some
bourbon and we can take some shots and
so the result of that is that while he's
gone they all basically sneaked off
because they're teenagers they do
exactly you would expect them to do
right see see here's this is an
important thing to understand right I
know it seems like it may not be super
important and it may not seem to seem to
be you know something to focus on the
fact that they snuck out but this is
what made the New Mutants and the
Generation X comics so
popular teenagers doing teenage things
teenagers with superpowers doing the
things that they would do if they had
superpowers right so like sneaking out
at night you know little things like
that and it wasn't necessarily all just
teenage mischief right there are some
really really really amazing stories
that came out of it but it was a small
little things like this that made it so
cool Daniel mu star kind of being the
mom of the group different things like
that it was cool house how this whole
thing went down the funny thing about
this is that when robert de constant
comes back it reminds me of that opening
scene from or not really the opening
scene but that scene from Robin Hood Men
in Tights right we're like Robin of
Loxley who's like hey look I want to
confess and I want to reveal everything
that I've done and so on and so forth
and all that kind of good stuff and the
the the prison guards like I'll go tell
the warden right sorry he's like he's
like I'm gonna get a promotion for this
everything's gonna be awesome so he
comes back and during the time that he's
gone
Pitts leads into Robin Hood and then
basically making their escape so the guy
comes back and he's like I told the
warden what was gonna happen I'm in DB
which was hilarious at the time and
that's kind of what this is right but
what you end up having here is is
basically them really like magic and
everybody having looked at where was the
starjammers we're gonna go to actually
teleport to that location when they get
there everything pops off and this is
when they learn the true nature of the
starjammers in terms of how they really
function as soon as the Star gamers get
in and they realize a new mutants are
there then when the star damage is like
our job is to steal stuff it's what we
do like we broke in here we stole things
and we're gonna leave and of course the
fighters are breaking out between the
New Mutants and the Shiar soldiers who
were there and the starjammers leave
them and that's the big thing about
about Corsair and his guys they don't
really care about you if you're there
and you can help them along their goal
that's cool but if you get in the way
then there's gonna leave you hangin and
that's just the way it is the
starjammers were almost always like that
the only real exception for that was for
the most part Cyclops Jean Grey and some
of the x-men as well as a result of that
you basically end up having the new
mutants who are essentially cornered and
then here's a cool thing you end up
having chamber Jonathan stars more
useless powers so for the character of
chamber he was kind of a mega level but
kind of not it was it was a little weird
when it came to him so when he
originally popped up he was basically
this guy who essentially had his
internal body totally destroyed by the
powers that he possessed this kind of
vile kinetic flame that's really a
byproduct of his really of like his
system his total psionic energy is what
he is right he's a being a composed of
pure psychic energy that just houses a
physical body as a result of that it
there was a point where really like for
years and years and years he kind of
maintained this way until you got into
the events of really the aftermath of
House of M and the
aftermath of house of M he was one of
the the mutants who consumed some of the
blood of apocalypse in new Excalibur
number nine and there became like
insanely powerful following that I'm
pretty sure it was after that you went
into New Mutants vol 3 issue number 24
as part of age of X and basically as
physical appearance was restored along
with his powers but Marvel never really
seemed to clarify whether or not he kept
any of the upgrades at apocalypse gate
and by virtue of the blood that he
consumed and I don't think Hickman's
really answering it here he may at some
point along the line but given the
nature of New Mutants in terms of what
we're seeing here it looks like it's
just classic versions of the characters
right so it would make sense that
because of the way he looks here that
he's basically classic Jonathan stars
more might suggest of being of pure
energy that houses a physical form it's
why you see that badge like that kind of
mask over his face is because if he
removes it like he does it's just like
this is this gaping maw inside of like
his throat in his chest and so on there
just emits huge forms of energy by the
issue with this he has control over it
but he hasn't reached the full potential
of it right so the result is that he's
able to kind of issue concussive blasts
more or less but it's not enough to
really just like incapacitate and
destroy everybody and so following that
you end up having the starjammers who
make their way back to back to their
ship and they basically tell like Robert
Acosta yeah like we left all your
friends there man I'm allowed to tell
you like they're all basically there but
we're getting ready to leave like we're
leaving right now and it's crazy because
de Caza says well what have they done
that gives you reason to just abandon
them like that and choads like they ruin
my plants and roses like the chick cut
off my arm and have suppose like I don't
like kids and I'm a Corsairs like they
they took my like you guys took my
whiskey and de castas like yeah but like
you lost that in a bet Nick where's like
what 90 lots of ships so get off my ship
it's funny like it's these funny little
modes it sees funny little nooks and
crannies and little things that make
this storytelling so incredibly cool but
the cool thing about this is that once
the cost it gets to where they are
ultimately it's like I would I know a
really good spatial a guy who didn't
basically get us out of this and it's
kind of okay so we're basically stuck
here right like they're captured by the
Shiar which really kind of begs the
question what comes next because for the
most part anybody who gets captured by
the Shiar it never really ends well
Corsair was captured by the Shiar along
with his wife and then like she was
knocked up by I think the kin and then
the baby was taken out ultimately became
Vulcan I think that's how that's how it
originally played out volcans origin is
weird there's two different versions for
Vulcan I can remember which ones which
but these never really ended well for
people and so as a result we get this
really really cool like Advertiser which
is basically like better call Saul
having legal trouble
justice is blind and so are we space
lawyer I would watch a show based on
that but anyway that's pretty much where
it ends guys so this is an amazing first
issue I absolutely love it but having
said we're gonna bring this video to an
end if you are new here to come this
explain to make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the Rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later
purse
[Music]